Es ist wieder schlimm aber ich kann echt nichts dran machen seit 1989 sind wohl drei viertel aller insekten verschwunden hallo
Das ist wirklich nicht gut also fast 30 jahre lang wurden mehr als 50 deutschen
Naturschutzparks, also die gebiete wo insekten eigentlich besonders geschützt sind untersucht das ergebnis ist dabei wirklich katastrophal wie es dazu kommen konnte
Und was dagegen getan werden kann jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja eigentlich ist es ja gar kein problem aber dann doch
75 prozent weniger insekten drei viertel weniger
Das sind wirklich beängstigende zahlen und insekten sind so ziemlich die wichtigste spezies auf unserem planeten
sie bestäuben
Pflanzen dienen vögeln und anderen arten als wertvolle nahrung und so weiter und so fort ein rückgang der insekten hat über kurz oder lang
dramatische auswirkungen auf die erde auf uns menschen in der zeitung die zeit wurde das auf
bemerkenswerte weise auf den punkt gebracht zitat wenn wir unserem ökosystem drei viertel des fundaments wegschlagen
Ist das ein massiver eingriff in die natur ordnung mit anderen worten das kann unsere erde töten
also
zu einem massensterben führen inklusive menschheit
riesenproblem viele insekten sind zudem mit bestimmten pflanzen eine art symbiose eingegangen sie leben voneinander
Stirbt das insekt
Aus wird das auch die pflanze treffen es wird eine schreckliche
kettenreaktion eintreten und sie hat ja schon begonnen auch die vögel dezimieren sich in deutschland durch das insekten sterben und auch
Europaweit wir hatten ja. Im mai. Darüber berichtet damals gab es eine, so genannte kleine anfrage, im bundestag
ergebnis es sind
57 prozent weniger tiere bei den brautpaaren in europa fast zwei drittel und bestimmte vogelarten
Trifft es besonders es gibt 80 prozent weniger kiebitze die rebhühner sind vom aussterben bedroht hier liegt der rückgang sogar bei
84 prozent bedroht sind weiter wachtel start turteltaube gartenrotschwanz braunkehlchen und so weiter und so fort
inklusive der vorwarnliste für vom aussterben bedrohte brutvögel sind
87 prozent der arten die betroffen sind fast 90 prozent das ist nah an alle furchtbar
wirklich wirklich stimmt wir müssen unbedingt handeln die menschheit muss handeln die gründe sind dabei sogar ziemlich simpel zitat
pestizide spielen mit sicherheit eine ganz große rolle wir können davon ausgehen dass es besonders bei kleinen
naturschutzgebieten durch verfrachtung über die luft zu einer kontamination der fläche kommt ja das sagt jan christian habel vom lehrstuhl für
Terrestrische ökologie der tu münchen im zdf
wenn schon in
naturschutzgebieten also da wo überhaupt kann ich chemikalien hinkommen sollen zu viele pestizide sind
dann heißt das dass in der landwirtschaft
Also da wo sie angewendet werden die alarmglocken?
Schrillen müssen und dabei könnte schnelles handeln wirklich hier helfen zum thema es ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm
Die vergangenheit hat gezeigt dass sich populationen sehr schnell wieder erholen können wenn ihnen die chance gegeben wird wenn sie allerdings einmal
Ausgestorben sind dann ist es vorbei
Und das droht dem moment pestizide müssen dringend stärker kontrolliert werden mehr
Mischkulturen biolandbau und so weiter und so fort sind dringend nötig und wir verbraucher können mit unseren einkäufen
Abstimmen ist kostet echt nicht so viel mehr gute bio produkte und die vielleicht bewusster
zu essen statt fast food in sich rein schauen man
Muss ja nicht päpstlicher als der papst sein aber ein bisschen bewussteres leben
Würde uns schon gut tun und vor allem der natur also ran an den speck
verzeihung an die bio gurken mehr infos gibt s übrigens beim naturschutzbund deutschland demnach
also
macht euch da mal schlau und zwar hier genau
draufklicken
unbedingt und wenn er kein video mehr zu diesem und zu allen anderen leben verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den
Auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit dem video zum vogelsterben das ist auch leider ziemlich dramatisch tja und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt kann